each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you all for coming it's a great
pleasure to have with us today Audrey
smokers artist is actually from avaya
labs and he earned his PhD from Carnegie
Mellon statistics he spent several years
at bell labs and then at via he's
actually going to talk to us today about
digital archaeology of software thank
you rip it off so very nice to be here
and not the first time hopefully not the
last I'll start from sort of high level
stuff of white to measure how to measure
what the hell is digital archaeology and
hopefully give examples that illustrate
it I wanted to start pretty early on
because you know nowadays we're all kind
of learn on technology especially me and
never have time to read sort of the
classics and I think we miss because I
sort of started reading that recently
and found that you know a lot of good
ideas I had seemed to have been stolen
from me you know 2500 years ago anyway
so why measure and one point is I wanted
to emphasize this to save our life and
another point is obviously to obtain
exact knowledge of the past as well yes
28 interpretation of the future which is
at least resembles the past if not
reflects it and so if I frame the
research question in very general terms
and perhaps you would find that too
general but you'll see how fully through
the
talk how it exemplifies into more
specific ones is that basically through
measurement obtained exact knowledge of
the past for the purpose of
interpretation of the future and that's
very important things think is is that
the knowledge that's useful for
interpretation of the future in another
part that I wanted to emphasize is that
human thing and the human things tend to
resemble themselves in the future well
sometimes computer things don't so so
those are kind of key dimensions that
I'll try to address and of course you
know at the end of the day well at least
you know either save our lives or at
least be content that's kind of the my
ultimate objective why software
developing why software development now
first it's really a if you think about
carefully it's a small reflection of
actual life but in a kind of more
constraint more specified more frame
more contextual version of real life
it's also supported that tools that
leave traces so we can actually measure
what's going on much easier finally it's
really a maturing discipline that's a
ripe ripe for more reproducibility and I
see in kind of near future the concept
of things like a just-in-time developer
sort of like call center operator who
comes in does the job and for that we
really need to understand exactly what
goes on how good developers do their
thing and how perhaps not so good
developers why they don't achieve that
the productivity of the good ones I
wanted to go a little bit and say why do
I call it a digital archaeology and I
wanted to start from a basic point is
that if you look at definition X is a
study of past human events and activity
so we can ask a test okay Patrice what's
X wait what is X
its history wrong ok B is is archaeology
why is archaeology fact now if I look at
what I'm trying to do is or many others
in this room instead of developer
cultures and behaviors through recovery
documentation and digital image you see
that it really is somewhere between
history and archeology except that it's
dealing instead of sort of artifacts
found in the ground perhaps with the
artifacts that are found on a computer
disk recorded somewhere now how do you
do that there's one similarity but it's
superficial as always there's a big
difference there are big differences as
well so one is that how do you actually
analyze those remains differs there you
have physical remains here you have
digital remains and again i would use
analogy so tomography image your
constructions for multiple projections
so if you think about main method of how
you deal of reconstruction the past here
from digital traces you basically look
at various projections and then you put
them together integrate into single view
that allows you to see the past so it's
sort of similar to tomography okay so
let me illustrate it on really basic
examples hopefully very quickly so on
bore you these are the things that you
really most of you at least really know
very well so task tools these are tools
that leave traces code tools they leave
traces other tools they leave traces and
they're all used in software development
very heavily for example let's take
tasks you open create a task perhaps
because user complains perhaps because
you want to implement the feature
perhaps you just want to change the code
and the process does not allow you to
change the code just willy-nilly you
have to open the task then assigned self
assign a person to solve a test then
submit the code then somebody verifies
that it's okay goes into release
everybody forgets it
okay so those are our example Mr systems
that deal with that so what kind of
traces do they live so this is an
example of a trace of status changes in
bugzilla bug number 4 1 2 2 3 3 and we
see a person who when what and initial
value and value okay and you said and
then you have a history of people that
work on that so that history of people
that history of states that all is the
traces of activity a bug resolution that
occurred for this particular bird what
we can do we can extract the information
about the sequence of people and
construct a graph for example there was
an instance where this developer are
opened perhaps greater the back
and this manager proved verified it or
proved it and so forth and so we create
a graph where each person in that
history is linked to another person
depending on the workflow so in this
case it's not mozilla this is some some
alya project with about 50 developers
where you can kind of use that
information to recreate actually
workload structure of the organization
so you see some managers that perhaps
are responsible for testing and
verifying so square is our testers oval
side developers and diamonds are sort of
technical managers so that's an example
of reconstruction it's a version control
system again trivial example there was a
few lines of code with some bugs in them
they were fixed comments added so one
line deleted to lanzetta 2 n's it
changed some other attributes who when a
comment it's at red sector etc so these
are basic basic traces that are being
left and somebody so if you look at CVS
lock in this case or nowadays it's it's
it's it's get log you will see okay
version person time again who when and
what happened perhaps in this case it's
linked to bug
so you can easily relate the code change
to a bug so that's a that's kind of a
raw data that's a trace that's left and
this is a really simple tool that takes
that trace and create something back
projects it into something that's useful
it says ok so these lines are created by
Dee barren inversion this these two
lines are created by this person and so
forth so you can see that this file is
actually modified a lot and multiple
people worked on that just by very quick
look at it but anyway so it goes so it's
a very simple reconstruction but it is a
reconstruction from those traces into
something useful I just wanted to
mention there are many many other
systems and perhaps you're familiar with
version control of backtracking but org
chart is one of the system sale
marketing information accounting and
maintenance support services and so
forth all of those things are recorded
in great excruciating detail and
basically right now the data is being
thrown out for the most part well what
do you do well how do you do this
archaeology so select phenomena observed
validate on a smaller scale does not
invalidate models for of the projection
on that smaller scale because you really
know what exactly happened from
qualitative data and that's different
from archaeology archaeology because
usually can go back in time and figure
out what's going on and then apply
suitable tomography methods and apply on
a wider scale and then see you know what
happens what the how things look on you
know perhaps bigger stank like ecosystem
and so forth so I'll try to do I'll
illustrate a one group of research
questions that form somewhat a story and
this starts from kind of individual
level questions asking about
productivity work transfer productivity
goes to kind of project level questions
at skills collaboration learning level
goes even higher leads to some questions
that lead to even higher community
perhaps organization like motivation of
people efficiency innovation and
and you know ends up with kind of
society or entire human species type of
level and I again through beauty these
are and quotes I'm really seeking this I
would like to think that too but I mean
according to at least plateau you can
have knowledge without truth and beauty
first because you know there's false
knowledge and unbeautiful knowledge and
we don't want that so let's look at that
let's start a the basic question so
let's take the context of global
software development wides there are
national policies customer presents
local expertise easily electronic
transfer of the product available in
expensive telecom communications I'll
just give you an example this is wasn't
given like in the 80s when Siemens
started software development in us to be
able to sell their switches they had the
development lab in Florida and the way
the way they did the synchronization of
the code they would ship with fedex you
know 20 tapes with all the code from
florida to munich and from munich to
florida back so that was the way you did
arcing in those days so now now of
course it's a little bit different
anyway lack of qualified IT workers in
some countries potential for lower costs
again I mentioned potential and
potential for round-the-clock
development and to some extent those are
true to some extent those are false but
this is kind of complicated story I
won't go into that the point is that
here's the question now let's see who's
right test okay Tom how many locations
globally distributed project may have
how many how many locations for a single
project
for
well yeah anybody can guess some other
number
is it going to wreck talking about I
mean somebody develop software from
someplace right so that's a location
okay okay okay location okay so so
there's some some on the South Pole by
the way so that's no and actually it's
more than some several hundred
developers but this is project that tom
knows really well and you should have
been able to give the answer correctly
this is five years s and these are the
main locations each one with at least a
hundred people many of them with more
like 300 or 400 people anyway so and
some of them with perhaps in April with
almost 2,000 people developers actually
working on the same piece of software
okay so funny things apart so let's
let's look at the question so now we
have this globally distributed software
we need to put development into a
different location because of all those
reasons that are beyond outside software
development their business reasons their
national politics reasons all sorts of
that when we do that somebody who
developed software no longer does that
somebody else develops that's offer so
we have this concept of succession that
is transfer of ownership for developing
some piece of software goes from one
person to another so let's define
implicit teams as groups that work on
similar parts of the software so that's
a Blissett team or virtual T and the
succession would be a transfer of
responsibilities to maintain and enhance
the product within an implicit team so
initially one person worked on that part
of the product then somebody else and of
course there in implicit team because
they work on the same part of the
product so receiving parties follower
transparent party will call mentor and
again those are just nominal terms you
have to look at the definition I mean in
principle I mean there are many cases I
mean those are not the most efficient
transfers but in many cases actually
meant and follower they don't even know
about each other's existence because
your transfer happens kind of outside
their fervor okay in in principle it's
always better for mentors pollos to
communicate because they can transfer a
lot of knowledge that way but in in
general that's not always the case so
the objective of this particular
phenomena is is is how do you measure
succession and in its impact so we can
have make some decisions about how to
work in the future so projection so I
already defined a little bit of what i
mean by succession and that gives some
idea of how it will be reflected in say
version control systems so engaging with
the code often leads to changing the
code so we can say okay whenever you
change the code you are related to part
of the code the chronological order of
engagements a by mentors and followers
should reflect the temporal order of
changes so as I said before mentor is
the one who starts and follower who
follows right so is after mantra so
that's those are two basic ideas of the
projection and if we want to reconstruct
to figure out who the mentor is we
basically pick first implicit teams and
that's very easy if you change the same
file with me we're on the same implicit
team we can define it that final level
or a higher level I like module or
perhaps by and succession would be
appears of developers where somehow we
define this reverse projection from
those from this data that we have that
really you know that that projection
that maximizes some criteria so I'll
just described one criteria even though
I tried a variety of them I'll describe
only the one that works really well and
the criteria is very simple suppose we
have two developers first developer made
two changes first change was done to
file one and second change was done to
file 2 and the second developer who
first change was done unfiled one end
the next two changes well done on file
to know time goes in this direction so
that for this file that was the first
change for this file this was the first
changed so you kind of sake okay so if
I'm
the first one I I should be a mentor
according to this file because i change
this part first but according to this
file this person should be the mantra
because you know they change this file
first so who is the right person here
because you have essentially a tie turns
out that if you wait each file by the
frequency so if you are the first before
some other person on one file then you
get one if you are a you know second
then you get after that another person
you get zero so for example developer m
gets one for this file gets zero for
this one so if you take the simplest
measure you basically get a tie you
don't know who is the mentor who is a
follower turns out that to resolve that
kind of tie what's useful is to look at
that how many people change that file so
if those two developers are the only
ones who change this file this file is
much more important than some other big
file where many other perhaps other
people change so so if you wait by that
frequency then you get you get a
slightly different measure which I
described and that basically says okay
this person is a mentor this person is
not because this file is not as
important in determining mentorship as a
spot period
the definition of mentorship meant your
prospective a single file you have
different all right so this is this this
set of mentors followers is defined on
people not on files so files are just
used as a way to figure out that that
relationship on people on those virtual
teams so files in some sense I
irrelevant to this what we want to know
is who is the mentor who is the follow
we really don't care what they work on
in that sense so so in order to compare
variety of signatures that I tried a
selected ten actually mentor follow
appears in a project that was actually
outsource and established the interviews
that here's the person who took over the
work here's the original person and
compared those signatures in terms of
how well they performed in terms
identifying the right pair actually
identify clearly identified where
interview and and there in the the
measure I just described on previous
slide worked quite well actually so now
I say okay I'm done so let's go to the
next step now I know I know who is the
mentor who is the Fowler and again I
should warn you it's not necessarily
that actual mentors are always
identified for example sometimes a
person a is very experienced he mentors
person be that person mentor persons
mentors person see and perhaps at some
point in time work is transferred or
some other reason and that the original
person mentors person d so your
signature points to person see as a
mentor of person d but in fact is the
person a mentor because that person was
most senior and perhaps he didn't have
anything else to do at that time or I
felt like doing that so so in this case
this is really more of a immediate
transition so it really doesn't always
identify the real true mentors in most
cases it does but in some cases it
doesn't so this but from from what I'm
trying to analyze this definition is
reasonably reasonably good anyway so now
now that identify those
earth I went out and said oh here's a
1100 developers in a vial for each one
let's identify who's who is a mentor who
is a follower well actually two thousand
and identified 1000 pairs and then I
said let's look at the some measure that
people with care about like for example
our followers as productive as mentors
so we look at the number of changes made
per month okay and we have about 2,000
people or 1,000 pairs and we have this
kind of ratio ratio so follower
productivity over mental productivity
now you can always object this is not a
very accurate measure of productivity
because you know if it's you I you make
a lot of changes if its server you make
very few changes that are very high
remember in this case they're all
working on the same code Oh similar code
because we determined that these are
people most close in terms of what code
they work yes what I'm trying to puzzle
out is what I would expect in a
succession is that sort of the mentors
productivity would be high and then go
to zero and then in the meanwhile the
followers would ramp up and really what
you want to know is steady state you
know was the steady state productivity
of the mentor sort of roughly the same
as the steady state in one of the
follower so in this case what I'm doing
is I'm saying okay let's take one year
period before the point where i define
transfer of ownership which is at the
point that follower starts working and
then when your prior let's see what
mentor does and let's see one of your
that what follower does that's so I
restrict in time because you know
eventually people move to other areas so
if you look at the bigger intervals it
won't work and I'm not really looking at
the curve over time just saying okay
here's one year what's the monthly
productivity of Metro one year what's a
month of productivity of the four yes
successful productivity of the mentor
will drop to zero ah product no no
proprietary of the mentor cannot drop to
zero because they have to make changes
before the follower right so okay so I'm
not looking the metra productive after
transfer okay and plus most of the
mentors actually move and do something
else so well so so in general that
that's not well we'll see the results
and that's not what you worry about
definitely not about dropping 20 by the
way actually quite opposite anyway so
what I try to do I said okay so let's
model this thing just do our regression
so take the productivity ratio take the
log of course because it's highly biased
and say okay time okay calendar time
well perhaps a while I was doing that
for 10 years perhaps they got better
perhaps you know over time this ratio
improved whether or not mentor offshore
so that's distributed development kind
of factory you know if mentor offshore
perhaps things are not going so well
because you can talk so well with it
sure primary area of expertise expertise
you know primary area of expertise so
mentors work on different parts of the
product on sometimes on multiple
products so on some products they have a
lot of experience on some are less
experienced so if you pick up a follower
and the mentor happens to be that's the
area of the men usually follower always
has a subset of files that the mentor
does right so so if this setup files is
not the primary expertise of the mantra
you know that's what it basically
indicate expertise breath how many
different areas experimenter has project
size and like three levels and number of
followers very simple ah now dropping 20
so ratio seems to be always at least
half and so you essentially if you if
you have everything else identical and
you have mentor offshore you have half
the productivity of that ratio so that
means the followers productivity drops
to a half of the mentors productivity
the only way you can graph a followers
productivity be equal or I mean for
obvious reasons equal or higher than
mentors productivity if you have small
project northshore development it's a
primary expertise of the
sir uh and there's very few followers
you know otherwise you you always get to
drop a project where we're about 50
projects actually ok but so you know one
thing Microsoft does for example and it
does handoff is the handoff is supposed
to be more maintenance mode where you
won't see as many changes but it sounds
like these are handoffs where you expect
development to just trying to continue
right but so so in fact many most of
those are handoffs where I mean some of
them by the way not mentor offshore
sometimes these are just regular people
joining the project and you know take
okay so right so the many of them most
of them are co-located actually it's
about perhaps one one quarter of them
are our offshore well variety of
practical implications that i'm pretty
sure you appreciate that in fact why i
had this empirical rule where they would
actually in offshore a location they
would had get four or five people to
replace somebody with a lot of
experience i'm not sure that really
works very well in many projects but at
least that match that rule you know
obviously we'd like to start with small
and new projects but nobody wants to
start with small a new project because
nobody wants to transfer those those are
cool interesting projects take more time
to transfer in some projects you know
it's like two months and they have to be
done don't overload mentors with too
many followers and focus on interest
primary expertise anyway so those are
some practical very simple practical
recommendations so so again let's scale
back and say well why do we see those
many followers that are you know quote
unquote so unproductive so that's the
kind of next step let's look at the
project level let's try to investigate
what's going on there so in particular
one aspect that i did mention i looked
at entire year period right but during
that period perhaps people weren't
really quite a competent you know and it
took while for them to become competent
perhaps part of the issue with a
follower productivity was that they just
were
really skilled you know didn't have
enough practice to be productive yet in
that one year after taking over so
looked at the concept of productivity a
little bit closer so you go like this
you say okay how long does it take for
your project to developers to become
productive yeah a small project oh you
know our like especially contractors all
it takes like two weeks or you know but
that's if you ask them harder questions
you know they'll get maps to two months
they have six months larger projects
perhaps you have my answer saying like
oh maybe 12 months or so but if you ask
a different question you asked what kind
of tasks do you do now what kind of test
did you do when you join the project you
get really completely opposite responses
you say oh it takes several years to do
competent in important tasks or we had
attempted to assign mentoring test
developers only two years of expertise
but I had really variances of Africa
results so we moved back to like at
least three years of expertise and so
forth are you also hear things like some
simple rules like you need at least two
or three release cycles before somebody
can really be competent resolving issues
so that's that all points out too much
longer periods of productivity so what's
going on why why this productivity is
not the same as competence okay another
definition I hope you can handle that
competency quality being adequately or
well qualified and productivities
quantity of tests completed per unit
time now fluency is the concept from I
guess speech therapy and it basically
idea is that if you have complex
sentences the complex grammar takes
longer for you to process them and
people slow and perhaps better some
fluency basically saying you you can be
productive you can do things in as rapid
as needed manner no matter how difficult
or important the task that's what
fluency so let's see if we can detect
those things in software developers so
first let's go
the first qualitative step so when the
vacation per month vertical axis tenure
horizontal axis there's a line and again
I should mention that first so this is a
model again apologize for using so many
models but let me explain so number of
modifications per month is their
response ID is a developer
identification right I mean first thing
that of course you here is the different
developers they do things differently so
most important thing is of course
developer so developer ID is number one
so this curve is really shape floor
average developer and so those numbers
would be I in fact is whoever happened
to be the first developer in that list
we added their coefficient and we added
and we got this this kind of curve
anyway but that's kind of there so in
some sense the absolute height is more
or less more or less random what matters
is really more relative height here okay
but you know we can see that it goes
almost goes up three times for this
large project over perhaps not a year
but perhaps 24 months and then it
flattens basically doesn't go up so so
to some extent they are true those
statements that you have get productive
pretty quickly they're true now i can
ask a question it shows 1105 that can be
the right time right it is oh we started
at 30 okay one hour passed I must be
dreaming okay and if you draw a same
line for shorter smaller projects you
get much much better results so you you
indeed see perhaps not to six months but
perhaps you see a plateau within seven
to ten months so people are a little bit
the optimistic as usual but but they're
not far off but if you ask people about
competencies then you suddenly get into
kind of two aspects really you get one
aspect is difficult so some tasks are
just difficult to do and unless you
really are very fluent
you can't really do them other task
perhaps aren't necessarily always very
difficult inherently but it's just not
clear what to do them or perhaps the
impact of doing them is so big that you
don't want people with that not enough
expertise do it now so that's difficulty
and centrality so these are developer
concerns these are mostly manage your
concerns of our architect insurance each
one has four dimensions and each and
each dimension has a mirror in in the
you know between difficulty it's a trout
it's so for example a typical thing is
technology people say okay technology oh
you know whatever Java is easier than
C++ you know some nonsense like that and
then perhaps working relationships you
know if you really need to deal with a
lot of people in your working
relationships that makes it more
difficult domain you know some user
interface is easier than perhaps server
customer issue oftentimes customer
issues are harder to reproduce not
always but sometimes they do and again
there's a mirror image in centrality in
some projects you know like in Microsoft
I'm pretty sure if it affects customer
you know there's a lot of it's important
so you don't want to screw it up you
want to provide a really good patch and
so forth so you wouldn't let the novice
to do that kind of task again domain if
it affects many parts of the system you
really don't want somebody with less
experience to do that team impact you
know if it affects it needs negotiations
communication with many people in the
team that's again long-term impact if
you change technology oftentimes you you
change the way you do things in the
future so that's another aspect that's
important so this line tries to look at
again a slightly different concept of
centrality of task and this centrality
of task is defined again that's the
response and again the same model idea
of developer and 10-year months in
project and in this case centrality is
okay so so each month let me try to be
very clear here each month you modify
some
Jules suppose you modify a module that's
really new and isolated nobody worked on
it okay so it has very little history so
in this case centrality is modeled by
the number of past changes to the module
so that will give you very low
centrality suppose on the other hand you
modify a module which has 20 year
history and has millions of changes so
that would be very high sensuality and
so overall the Amar's that you do a
month you calculate average centrality
for each developer and then you fit this
particular model and then what you see
is that over three years you really
don't see any plateaus whatsoever again
that's for a large project for smaller
projects might be slightly different and
it depends really on the different types
of centrality that you define but the
point is really that three years might
not be enough to reach fluency that's
really the key point of their of this
chart by the way I want you to make sure
you don't confuse with productivity
because centrality i have not mapped
centrality to value or anything of that
sort we all know that you know moves
this whatever that number is it moved
for 7.5 to 9 and 10 is it thirty percent
better than 7.5 or is it 100 percent
better is it a million times better I
don't know the point is unless you have
somebody with three years of experience
you probably can't even do those desks
this is for just one
this state ID here how quickly it be
baby pen if there's a lot of turnaround
in the project if you have the same
people for three years and so God will
do this transwell work at the beginning
will do so the central work at the end
so or it's going slower we should take
an organization the start that's
doubling its own force already you will
be moving to the central stuff much
faster perhaps yeah that's a good quite
a good pocket yeah okay dimensions many
dimensions of difficulty dimensions of
centrality you can measure that quantify
growth of fluency and again you know
again it's like you can't do it in two
weeks basically that's the simple moral
and it's very important also to retain
experienced staff because if you don't
have people at least one person with
experience in a project I mean and and
it's you can see in a buy it over and
over again it really you know it really
destroys the project okay so let's go we
see how at the project level we came up
with this kind of measures of fluency it
increases or time but the developers
really vary with each other why you know
what's the reasons for the variance
among developers why some grow so so
much faster than others I mean I've
showed that average but one of the first
things that people say is that some
developers just never you know never get
off the ground and that's that's this
thing that I is not reflected but that
was kind of a puzzle try to address so
that led to this concept of okay so how
do people actually learn in organization
so there's social aspect and technical
aspects so let's separate this scalar of
luhan's into two parts so technical
competences again let's measure
something really simple number of tasks
completed so that's practice number has
completed everybody knows you play
violin you get better at it you program
you get better and social competence is
is basically how many different
individuals you encounter your workflow
and let's call relative sociality
is the ratio of the two so I I picked
that this is a medium-sized project I
picked the project and a fit the line
which is I looking at just social
learning so total number of people you
encountered in your workflow and I you
know good condition on developer ID when
they started because you know they could
have been changes over time how big the
project size was at the time and then
ten years on this horizontal side so
unlike that lines that plateaued or the
line that grew up straight this is by
the way it looks at eight years so
that's much longer period so really
wanted to see what happens beyond that
three-year period what you see is first
of all some sort of bumps but also what
you see is that there's some increases
after perhaps a half a year you see
increase in learning then it slows down
then you after three and a half years
you see increase and so forth so there's
some some perhaps cycles there I
wouldn't over interpret those so this is
really kind of early data but really
surprising stuff is that really perhaps
learning accelerates not necessarily
accelerates now there is a simple
explanation of course after four years
many people become managers and so forth
at least technical lead and that allows
them to talk with other people as well
but that really fits into that model
that perhaps you you reach sort of a
plateau of your technical competence and
perhaps then you need to increase your
social competence in order to continue
technical conferences and vice versa and
this kind of cycle repeats itself over
time what's most surprising is that that
that that instead of learning slowing
down it actually appears to accelerate
so let's ask the other question so those
are people that obviously state for
eight years or ten years in the project
why do they stay for so long so this is
a very special group are we looking at
really strange people here so one of the
things is that we all know that we're
sort of affected by initial environment
you join a organization and then your
first impressions really do a lot of
things to you about how you
behave in the future so this was an
attempt to look at that from software
developers perspective so what happens
if project social and relative sociality
is high or low you know if projects
relative sociality is low perhaps
joiners may receive more support and
attention from existing members because
you know they have more time and perhaps
they perhaps appreciate more external
contributors so that's more applies to
open source but you have similar
arguments for commercial projects as
well perhaps were a few people coming in
you still have a lot of work but perhaps
business is not so good so you really
appreciate and train those new people
better while if if you have a high
sociality than perhaps there is not much
time to really spend on mentoring
activities and perhaps the appreciation
of contributions isn't as good so the
joiner who will be more likely to become
a long-term contributor and that's
another definition somebody who stays
for three or more years within the
project and this is kind of an important
concept because if you think about a
software project if somebody just joins
for a few months and leaves perhaps
effort spent on mentoring that person
was bigger than actually value the
project gets so that's kind of why this
this definition is is important and
given that there's at least three years
that you need to kind of get to get up
the update of the level you know that's
perhaps a reasonable definition but
perhaps the defense on the project
perhaps for some projects ten years is
that long-term contributor for us maybe
maybe it's two years ah so what I plot
here is the survival curve for members
in the project so rad have I have
acquired nortel and so now we have this
nortel blue or avoid and a wire blue so
if I blue I think is the part that came
from norcal avaya red is the part that
came from loosen anyway so just to give
you an explanation nortel is kind of
also a telecom company it's just a split
from AT&T many eons ago and the
interesting part that it has exactly the
same portfolio as a vial because if i
just bought the enterprise part of north
tell so we have all the same products we
have a product
the same number of people so it's
interesting to compare the two so the
survival curve let me give you an
example how survival curve is
interpreted so here's the number of
months with the project it goes from 0
to 250 and then there's four people who
join at the loews at the low relative
sociality levels it's this line with
else and high and million are those
other two light so you see for each
voyage so you see say 450 so pics
hundred fifty so you say that people who
join that low sociality about eighteen
percent state at least 150 months with
the project okay and uh and in for
people who join during medium and high
sociality there is maybe about five
percent so there's about three times
difference between the two now we see a
look at the blue which is another part
of a playa you see you see actually a
very different picture and I could get
into explanation perhaps why it may be
so but you see a very different pattern
it's much bigger difference between the
between the two groups okay and here's
some two projects parallel projects one
project in a while one project in hotel
that are do exactly the same say this is
Mozilla this is open source project and
again you see are you see also and this
is a deliv gnome where it's the cromeus
so you see that there's some variation
between projects why there is variation
even though well I guess no man Mozilla
both user interface but they're quite
different but but these are really in
tentacle functionality and these
companies are also identical so why
there is such a difference between the
two so that leads to our next question
which is perhaps there are some culture
differences so perhaps we could look at
the even higher level at society and see
what's going on here so what I did here
is I extracted those eight hundred or so
different wikipedias this is English
this is Swedish this is Chinese I just
plot the kind of just for fun I plotted
the activity in each one of the
is and also looked at the relative
sociality which is calculated not with
respect to mr but with respect to a
particular article which people edit it
and again you see very similar pattern
though in Wikipedia is that pattern
perhaps is more due to the fact that the
relative sociality in the beginning was
much lower than at the end and people at
the beginning are more likely to stay
longer than the ones that joint at the
end so it seems that if you really look
at the increase in 10 years so you can
actually go and say what the percentage
increase in predicted tenure and so you
pick up IFR I overall you get about
sixty percent increase in tenure folk
known perhaps one hundred percent so you
double for Mozilla perhaps not much and
so forth and then you see Mozilla is
kind of similar like Chinese Wikipedia
so you say okay so perhaps there are
some cultures that are both in
development and perhaps at the national
level that that have effects that we're
observing the differences of how to
finish the talk I wanted to just quickly
go over some other things that I think
are important to realize one is that I
noticed over time that it's good to look
at individual project but some questions
very difficult to answer if you just
look at individual project so perhaps
you want to look at the entire company
like code growth productivity and so
forth perhaps you want you to look at
the Thai culture say an open source and
so forth and and for that purpose i'm
trying to collect data that's covers
both all the open source and hopefully
you know all the industry and there's
some collaborators that provide some
equipment and and you know network
equipment etc and I listed all listed
those here so a via stuff is done of
course on alya systems but those other
things are done on those other systems
as well so I wanted to give an example
so so here is all the defects in alya
and nortel combined and what I'm
plotting over time is number of people
involved in resolving them so I'm not
plotting number of people in
employed I'm just a number of people
involved in the work flows in those
defects okay and it kind of grows and
goes down you know after the I guess you
know nortel went bankrupt you know Alya
wasn't doing that well they bought
nortel so it went down quite substantial
right the number of people but if you
look at that green line which is the
activity actions it's like a sign Mr
resolve mr do transferred work and so
forth the actions in those mrs or number
of mrs really doesn't doesn't drop it
continues on so you can kind of say ok
there seems to be a huge productivity
increase there and if you go backwards
in time perhaps you also can see also
some sort of productivity increase at
this point again that's another time of
perhaps downsizing after the internet a
bubble burst as regards to this all
version control systems in the world
this was data from collected from four
years ago and at that time you know the
so that's a vaya then there is for Jess
and so forth and an amount of code
amount of changes etc just to give an
idea at this time I had about 150 180
maybe two hundred thousand different
version control depositors right now I
have a list of of around 600,000
positive so it's been a kind of an
explosion in terms of of the amount of
code that's being put out and at that
time I said look I mean in a liar we
almost have more code that in all open
source but that really a chain is
rapidly changing as we speak
so let's get back to this conclusion
that trying to either save ourselves or
be content that I think it's being many
times mentioned that you know how much
can you do about a version control data
I mean over the years but I noticed that
many universities many companies they
really invest very heavily in in
software mining right now and I don't
think that's a bubble I think there's
the value that could be extracted it's
still very high it's just the question
is how do you make sure that those
projections are really relevant at least
to yourself perhaps the project
community society and perhaps that that
last thing so that's that's all thank
you very much it is a data point
it's michael good press sorry by taking
so much time I just couldn't contain
myself so you said you're recording i'll
just pick on the end of the thought you
said you're recording 600,000 projects
and no yeah that's right and up their
old bird industry
it's probably not feasible to run the
experiments on all of them like the
kinds of things that you right now well
not in that detail so that's the point
is that you ask different questions and
try to so my main main point is what I'm
trying to do with those two Buster's is
I create a huge hash table where I put
all the kontiki is the content of each
version of each file and then I'm saying
okay in which projects is this file a
curse and then I do transitive closure
I'm saying give this files occur if this
version matches that version in those
two projects then the entire version
histories must match so I'm saying okay
Lisa actually parallel developments of
the same functionality I can answer a
little bit different actual copy format
like so you're recording all this stuff
before you have an idea of what
experiment or one study you want to on
the data and it sounds like that's a
great social services that were publicly
available for any set of huge number of
grad students who want to do data might
good what benefits does it give you or
abaya to built this huge repository as
opposed to term only gathering it as we
discussed it there's two yeah so so so
let me get that's a very good question
so I have this other aspect which is I
try to do data salvaging for example
many of the nortel products of course
will be discontinued or avaya products
and so I'm trying to kind of recover
that before it disappears because you
know we've got 30 years of you know
thousands of people working on some
pretty good products that will go out
the window so something could be learned
from that so I'm looking at that as data
salvaging in many open-source projects
in fact do data does disappear and so
forth well I look at it as public
service list but this this way I mean my
feeling is if I won't do it nobody else
will do so you know so i might as well
do it so and then hopefully somebody
gets in part it takes it over so some
extent i'm having success i but but yeah
it's
for why principally what Alya use I mean
I right now I moved it off of a service
for the most part but for ye the
principal value is that I mean one of
the things you can do you basically say
I can say okay here's a by code here's a
vehicle that's borrowed from open source
because I have a version or you know
similarity to this project there so that
way at least I can say what's a why
what's not a why and you know in many
cases you know there's all sorts of
licensing issues that could be you know
that's actually quite useful services
like that I fairly expensive and people
have business models in that I'm not
really trying to get into that space but
I do have some questions I mean I didn't
have time to really talk about but they
have a number of questions which I think
can be answered only if you have a full
set like for example copying you know
innovation right spread of innovation
they have just one project you really
can't say you know how much innovation
is an open source just impossible and
even if you have sample it's very
difficult but with the complete set of
sensors you can answer I mean similar if
you think if you think of why census is
done I mean sometimes its political
reasons but other reasons more kind of
business reasons that's basically the
same reasoning you can apply to hear so
as I am for instance I mean and
regarding distributed development I do
have you ever been able to reach some
conclusions that the management paid to
attention to or is it after the fact
basically you okay so let's put this way
I mean in some sense how high is a great
place to do study because there's so
many confident decisions it seems to be
made but you know let's uh but I think
that's being done everywhere I think
Microsoft probably doesn't does have its
own share of things and and let's
understand that they are incompetent
perhaps from software development
perspective perhaps those decisions are
reasonable from business perspective as
you go through life I cannot start to
understand that now however stupid it
seems from you know
software development perspective
sometimes there's a good business reason
or perhaps you know somebody benefits
from it anyway so the so that's the
first point second point is for example
I really my study off organizational
change and the wire has like thirty
percent sure I mean it's a right now our
you know many projects well I mean that
basically i'll give you an i don't want
to be too winded but so we outsource
some of this stuff to i believe we pro
and one of the projects was outsourced
to them and their guarantee and whatever
they agreed is for two years for people
to stay on the project well what they
didn't think of is that after they stay
for two years they move on one hundred
percent what do you do then when you
have a release to two months down the
road so anyway that's a you know so so I
mean you can argue that there isn't
foresight but but there are a number of
things that for example those contra
those experts hired as contractors were
as a result of that as you know really
come you know they really stopped
offshoring for you know half a year or a
year just to kind of get back and say
okay you know let's do it better so so
it's you know so there are some
signature science you just mentioned the
distinction between looking at these
histories from a software development
perspective versus a business
perspective
and actually the business perspective
something I don't like fair share and
suffer mining as well but the business
perspective is something that I would
always be very interested in but where I
would have lots of difficulties actually
acquiring the appropriate data because a
for instance them for instance it was
like before open source projects it's
always a most impossible to get a
reasonable estimate of effort that went
into individual changes and you cannot
simply take chain the number of changes
of the process that because the same
effort will flow into one single
combined change right as well as it
depends how people work and so forth
another thing is another thing also from
a more economical perspective is that
shin not all changes are not all
consequences are equal so they obviously
are they're very obviously bugs which
are which must be worth hundreds of
thousands of dollars because some of my
students are correct I currently
collecting this into in bug bounties
mm-hm there's many other bugs which are
simply chess in victorville and comes to
fix many bugs actually I know our
evening nobody delivers absolutely would
be because they would simply improve
maintenance if if anything if you do a
few aesthetic bad checker and you think
maybe some ice my answer is it will
provide your employment for a long time
initiation not so simple I mean that
meant that the whole point and I
completely agree with all those
statements and I think that's why we
need skill that's why we need people
that understand how to do that well
because otherwise you know you you know
if unless you take care of how we do
things but I'm sorry for interrupting
but perhaps you haven't finished your
point but I completely agree with that
yes best one is actually I'm not trying
to raise a point to my profession so
what does this imply for the collection
of data and also what does this so in
terms of effort in button
and what does this and also as it comes
to the ethical to risk if there's a very
few the very small number of issues
which may be worth Williams and millions
of issues with cable network how does
this help how can we reflect this in
research so so so let me just go so the
methodology is really has been developed
by that guy that did this history stuff
I mean that's that's a guy who really
did all day I mean if you read I mean he
summarizes how he he verified the data
how he collected how and so forth it was
a partly numeric data portly opinion
data but you know he did that a long
time ago and if you read carefully
that's really how you should do
empirical work other thing is so that's
really i mean i'm not going to
contribute anything there what I'm going
to say though is that it really depends
on what you're trying to do so if you're
trying to look at bugs as a cost it does
you know the important box perhaps
aren't as much difficult different as
small bugs as long as they take time to
cook if you're really looking at
customer impact that's a completely
different story then perhaps you should
focus on if you look at the safety
issues then then that's even yet another
story so that's my kind of point that
you know from quality perspective you
really need to pick a domain a context
and then understand exactly what you're
trying to do before saying that this is
the right thing to do and I don't think
there is a right answer and that's why I
think there's a lot of work for us to
figure out what are the right domains
how'd what they do in each one what's
the you know the right measure for each
well so I certainly agree with
what do you think you're missing when
you get the electronic uh stories but
you don't have
people be you know the NPDB story of vh1
you know story of each person and what
they did for the project 25 what their
motivation was yeah so that's why that's
the next place I want to go is to figure
out motivation so my hope is as follows
is like archaeologists do the same thing
right they don't have any contact with
those people that died perhaps twenty
thousand years but what I'm using is
this this phrase by foo seized it is
that says he kind of nicely said human
things we're past resembles the future
if it doesn't reflect it so the point is
you can learn about something from where
you you can actually talk to people and
it's then what they're doing and what
traces they leave and then extrapolate
that appropriately to instances where
you don't have any contact and that's
really the my primary kind of borrowing
your strength of six explanation there
this terminology in statistics but I
mean that's kind of the main main idea
is is because yeah you always will have
a lot of stuff where you have you know
people died basically so you don't know
what's to
is that and then
and this is ultra policy perhaps is that
next next way